elle ne dure que trois mois dans l'année
et pourtant la saison des asperges de
créer une véritable crise politique en
allemagne
ces travailleurs roumains viennent
chaque année récolter des milliers de
tonnes de pointe blanche
mais le sort de ses ouvriers agricoles a
été particulièrement difficile en cette
période de pandémie
la grande majorité vivent dans des
logements insalubres situé à proximité
d'une station d'épuration
[Musique]
compte tenu du fait que les gens sont
sortis et on travaillait tous les jours
dès l'aube sans masque chirurgical sur
la bouche
entassés dans des bus parfois ils nous
donnaient des masques parfois non de
plus ils étaient insultés dans les
champs et mal traités comme des chiens
la nourriture ne serait même pas bonne
pour des cochons et ils ont eu l'audace
de payer 400 euros par personne donc 800
euros pour deux personnes
mais les conditions du contrat n'ont pas
été respectées il était impossible de
passer un printemps sans asperges en
allemagne les exploitations agricoles
ont obtenu du gouvernement
l'autorisation d'organiser un pont
aérien pour faire venir de la main
d'oeuvre bon marché directement venus
d'europe de l'est et ce malgré la
fermeture des frontières en europe le
coronavirus a mis en lumière les zones
d'ombré autour de ces fraudes massives
en allemagne et plus généralement sur le
continent soudain les gens qui sont
utiles au système qui étaient traités
comme des déchets cela va prendre du
temps mais vous verrez ils vont réaliser
qu'ils ont leur mot à dire toute notre
production alimentaire dépend d'eux des
gens qui travaillent ici dans les champs
ils vont voir d'eux mêmes qu'ils ont le
pouvoir de commencer à changer des
choses
ils ne font pas ce travail par plaisir
mais parce qu'ils viennent de pays à
très bas salaires de pays très pauvres
[Musique]
c'est travailleurs détachés ne sont
couverts par aucun régime d'assurance
maladie ce qui les rend encore plus
vulnérables en pleine pandémie
lors du week-end de pâques un ouvrier
agricole roumain de 57 ans venu en
allemagne est mort du co vite 19